and i paid 77 for
a covid test a blood test and a ct
a cat scan yeah which is like americans
are probably
like losing that like like a ct scan
for 77 i got the breakdown and the
covert test was 600 yen
so like five dollars like five bucks
yeah yeah it was like nothing
because i yeah because i remember i had
to take aki to the hospital once like
this was like a year ago yeah right
she i think she like squirted like
shampoo
oh yeah i remember that and she was like
i can't see i think i've gone blind so i
had to call up the hospital
obviously get an ambulance over and
everything and the entire right she was
such an american mindset the entire ride
to the hospital she's like
oh my god this is going to be so
expensive isn't it like this this
thing's going to be
and i'm just like don't worry about it
we'll just fix your eye or whatever yeah
we get to the hospital it's like 2 a.m
yeah we get to the hospital
dr late does a you know quick little
check and she's like okay you're all
good you're not blind or anything you're
just it's just really red it's really
burnt out
we washed it out for you uh you know
here take some
meds and you'll be all good yeah and
then in japanese hospitals
there's like a kiosk that you have to go
to to like pay for it
yeah yeah yeah right so we go to the
kiosk with like this little uh
receipt and we're just like oh my god
this is gonna be like
a couple hundred bucks an hour that's
right because she's thinking in the
american america and i had never really
gone to a japanese hospital before so i
had no idea either i was like oh [ __ ] is
that the same as like
if she says it's like a couple hundred
bucks then i guess i'm prepared to spend
a couple hundred bucks yeah dude it was
like twelve dollars
and we looked at it and she's like wait
ambulances are free
because in america you have to pay like
two three hundred dollars to get a
[ __ ] ambulance
yeah i think it's more i think it's like
a thousand something like that like i
i've heard stories of like a couple of
my american friends who had like
broke their arm for example and they're
like call an uber yeah yeah
it's like because we're not paying for a
[ __ ] area so we're just going to call
a
a thread yeah it's tragic because like i
think i remember
aki wanted to get an allergy test in uh
uh not in australia in america and it
was like eight hundred dollars
for an allergy test here you'd pay like
ten dollars
for an allergy test right yeah and i
guess in like the uk
yeah because do you guys have free
health care yeah yeah we have free
health care yeah yeah yeah yeah um
i think doctors won't give you stuff
like that though unless they think you
need it yeah like so it's kind of hard
to get stuff like that all right because
in australia like you can go get an
allergy test whenever for free yeah
maybe i don't know i've never done that
it's very some some very specific
medicines you get for free others you
kind of have to pay for
um i i feel like with uk it's very
specific on what
illness you have because sometimes you
have like this really common illness
they just tell you to just go home and
sleep it off basically
yeah uk doctors a lot of the time are
very reluctant to like do anything
yeah i mean i don't i can't i mean at
least the doctors i've had yeah and if
you just go to like a general
practitioner right like to
get a checkup it's usually free right
yeah yeah whereas the only other
i guess experience i've had with
healthcare outside of the uk is thailand
and
normally it's like pretty it's pretty
like it's about the same price as it is
here in terms of
medicine and going to see the doctors
and everything and what i found is that
doctors here um in asia at least are way
more willing to give off
like some kind of medicine for whatever
illness you have i guess there's an
argument that also could be dangerous
though like just getting off medicine
constantly i mean that's why there's
like an opioid epidemic right now in
america
yeah yeah yeah over prescribing but i
mean healthcare is a
a loaded topic so that's another topic
that we
that i certainly do not know enough
about to contribute to the conversation
i had a good time my doctors were very
nice except they scared the [ __ ] out of
me
you know that was literally yeah
i'm still several times several times
actually another thing that was good is
like there was a pharmacy like right
around the corner and
i they obviously knew i couldn't speak
japanese i told them i was like nihongo
or
what kind of knife and then they were
they made me feel out of form in english
and i was like [ __ ] how do i tell them i
have like
this blood condition yeah and so i
googled the kanji for it
and i like wrote this kanji which is
[ __ ] hard kanji that was like like
swooshes when there's not lines
straight lines there's a curve in this
damn it yeah yeah
and then i had to write this in like it
must look like a two-year-old
i really want to see that now i don't
know whatever the kanji for hemophilia
is is on the screen right
right right right yeah it was and so i
gave it and i'm like you
i was like i made sure i was like does
your buddy die and they're like oh yeah
and they gave me uh the medicine and
then they gave me a printed like a4
paper
in english explaining what all the
medicine was and one if i
shouldn't take it that's cool yeah yeah
because normally in japan it's just like
oh you don't speak japanese
oh [ __ ] i think this medicine will work
you might have a
reaction to it
like better find it because like most
american medicine like i can't take
like and i always find that out because
when i was a kid i didn't give a [ __ ]
i was like i'll take it
and then when i got older and i started
like you know when someone told me like
you can't take ibuprofen and my dad had
been giving me ibuprofen for like five
years oh my god
and it was like oh [ __ ] i could have
like died yeah yeah yeah so i can't take
like ibuprofen and there's so many drugs
in america that contain stuff that i
just can't have so like i can't have
like other
generic ones as a kid did you love the
taste of like calpol
i think i think
yeah just like general cold medicine but
as a kid it tasted it tasted
way too good i still love getting sick
every time i would have a sick day i'm
like mom bring out the cowboy
cracking bottles get the top shelf
like i'm only like because you're only
supposed to take like one spoonful
sometimes i just act like extra ill
enough so i could be like
i think i need another one because that
[ __ ] tastes
too good to be a medicine we had we had
something like that in australia but it
was cough syrup yeah right and like
you normally it's it's like strawberry
flavored cough syrup right yeah
and like it still tastes like coffee it
has the aftertaste of cough syrup but
the
the initial thing is like a group of
like strawberry flavored like jelly but
exactly so kids would just like [ __ ]
downy shots of that [ __ ]